okay one of the things I want to touch
on before we wrap up today's program and
go to voicemail and then ultimately the
bonus show is where is our audience
generally on sort of the consequences
that President Trump may or may not ever
face for the different things that he
has allegedly done we did a poll
yesterday on our YouTube community tab
where we asked which is most likely to
take down Trump if any more than 10,000
of you voted we are putting the results
up which I will tell you in a moment
this is not a scientific poll normal
disclaimers this is indicative merely of
the opinion of the people in our
audience who chose to participate 49% of
our audience believes that there will be
no consequences at all for Donald Trump
period the other 51% of the audience is
split among four options 25% believe
that the new real estate tax fraud
investigation is ultimately what is
going to take down Donald Trump 17%
believe that it's the Trump Russia
investigation that will lead to real
consequences for Trump 7% believe that
it is the cognitive decline or being
found unfit to serve maybe via the 25th
amendment as the mechanism for his
removal that will lead to consequences
and not hugely surprisingly only 2% of
our audience believes that the illegal
mistress hush money payments will lead
to his downfall which makes sense
because I I don't really see how how
those could this is probably correct
that's the reality
it is probably correct to to say what a
plurality of our audience says which is
that there aren't going to be
consequences for Donald Trump at least
not serious ones when it comes to any of
the stuff that he's been involved in and
this is likely for for a combination of
reasons number one that the consensus
from the legal community does seem to be
that there is no indict us itting
president number two that impeaching
Trump in advance of an indictment is
going to be a massive uphill battle
number three that there is going to be a
massive movement to protect Trump that
includes the Supreme Court and as we
talked about yesterday the appointment
of Brett Kavanaugh to the court is
absolutely part of that so it's probably
correct that the most likely outcome is
there are no consequences for Donald
Trump for all of the different stuff
that he and his family have been
involved in but that's not a reason to
stop pushing when we see bad things done
we have supposedly a free press we have
the ability to go out and protest
although not so much the availability as
I've spoken about people who have to
work they've got to work for a living
wages have been stagnant you're not
necessarily able to start taking time
off from work in order to protest but
anytime we see what we perceive to be
wrongdoing we should be calling for
investigations critical media should be
continuing to do investigative
journalism it all should happen and
needs to continue happening but you know
I'm not an unrealistic person I get that
every single one of these paths of
holding Trump accountable are
significantly uphill battles let's not
be discouraged because we can still vote
out anybody we want to vote out and I
hope that people will do that in four
and a half weeks in the midterm
elections to send an initial signal that
this is not going to be tolerated I hope
people will do that remains to be seen
today's show was made possible in part
by Scion Games and their new game for
phone and tablet called antidote which
is an award-winning strategy game it's
all about using vaccines to defend the
human body from bacteria and viruses
it's fast paced the graphics are amazing
the game has actually been commended by
the World Health Organization because it
has a mission to fight back against anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on YouTube I've put the
links under the video